[Music]
this is crazy because this is on
national television and it was a very
popular show i don't know if it still is
but it's out there family feud
long running show
and as you know there's different
families they they feud against each
other hence the name family feud i
haven't watched it since richard dawson
was the host wow
what was that the 60s when was it i
think he's dead now
and there's a new guy hosting it right
yes steve harvey oh yeah you know him
so steve harvey's hosting this show and
one of the contestants that's a part of
this family the question was all about a
milestone you'd love to achieve
let's play the clip let's play it play
that james
give me a milestone people achieve they
can be proud of
well one day
i would like to have no debt
yes
that's not going to happen
debt is okay
opm other people's money
is how you get rich
you use other people's money not yours
that's how you get rich
dave i want to punch something and
you're the closest thing next to me and
so i'm going to refrain
you know
here's the thing
if you're a game show host
that's cool
but you probably ought to just like host
the game show
and not and not give out financial
advice for one thing the second thing
you shouldn't do
is give out financial advice if you're
25 million dollars in debt to the irs
you just airing out some laundry here
i'm just saying when you google steve
harvey
you find out he's 25 million dollars in
debt to the irs so if you're 25 million
dollars in the debt in debt the irs when
it comes to money advice you should shut
up
you really should not open your yap
real i mean
and on top of that be a dream killer for
a young guy yeah that's what gets you on
this show i mean if you want to just be
stupid and 25 million dollars in debt to
the irs and have your little game show
that's fine but when you're a dream
killer and you rile george up that'll
get you on this show listen here's the
thing steve harvey is a celebrity he's a
media mogul he makes his money in a lot
of ways this young guy being funny yeah
is where he makes his money so try that
but to donate more often and you won't
be 25 million dollars in debt this idea
that this guy's debt
is a bad thing to pay off because it's
other people's money and therefore it's
good debt and this is how we build
wealth it just occurred to me steve
harvey is using other people's money
mine
your money and yours we're taxpayers
he hasn't paid his tax bill 25 million
dollars worth he is using opm there you
are
they figured it out
followed his follow his own advice this
is crazy he's he's living the dream
use opm let's use the taxpayers money
just don't pay our taxes 25 million
dollars in debt i would love to see
steve host a financial show when they
call and say steve i'd love to pay off
my debt can you tell me how and he goes
well you got to get more debt man you're
doing great keep it up
you're not quite there yet
i can free up some cash flow for you
don't pay your taxes
that's one way to do it
not a way i'd recommend
hey listen steve we would have left you
alone brother but you know what happened
you you stepped on a young man's dream
and you walked over into our garden when
you did it
and uh so a pruning is in order
uh so that's what you're experiencing
young man uh stay in your lane brother
and you'll be okay with us we love you
we think you're funny we think you're a
great guy don't be a dream killer though
and if that contestant is listening i
want you to call us up because we will
actually help you actually we'll give
them a free
subscription for a year to ramsey plus
so they can get into financial peace
university and we'll get them out of
debt i will personally the opposite of a
dream killer yeah i want to see that
that's like a make-a-wish foundation
we're on the other side of dream if
anyone contacts me and i'm their one
make-a-wish they've led a sad life dave
hopefully they have bigger dreams i
wasn't saying you were the male wish i
said we're gonna let them make a wish
when it comes to being wealthy we're
going to help them get there oh okay
that's different george it was not
personal i thought you meant their wish
would be to hang out with me
well it could be
it could happen
thanks
we can aspire to that dave's not a dream
killer i'm not a dream i'm gonna let you
live your dream george
but hey listen if you're out there
listening you're part of the skipper's
family that was on the family feud hit
me up i will personally financially
coach you uh because our our friend
steve didn't do a good job of that
well yeah
condescending dream killer man ain't
going to happen not going to happen it
sounds like p.m
opm other people's money use the
taxpayers money
now dave
i think what he's referring to you know
if steve calls us up we'll help him with
his tax debt if she calls it off we'll
give him a debt snowball with the irs
going i'll give him a free membership to
ramsey plus how's that gonna get him a
debt snowball for because then you know
i mean he would actually help the
general deficit with 25 million being
repaid that is true because the deficit
i think he's repaid i've got the article
did he repay it it sounds like he he oh
he worked his way out of it look at that
he got it he had a few big deals come
through oh
wow
a few big deals came through and he so
he's not he so he's not the cause of the
current deficit just the past deficit
yep
okay yeah well he's using that opm
principle pretty well though well what
it comes down to is he's saying you've
got to leverage as much debt as possible
and that is the key to wealth building
yeah which is the antithesis
to
how you now how long was that clip james
you know off top of your head 30 seconds
roll it one more time i want to show it
one more time
give me a milestone people achieve they
can be proud of
well one day
i would like to have no debt
yes
no dad no dad that's not gonna happen
it's opposite day opm other people's
money
is how you get rich
you use other people's money not yours
that's how you get rich
the federal government's other people's
money i love the lady in the background
looking around going is he serious right
now did he really just say that what
what what what what oh man they expect
me to run out with like a rubber club or
something and start hitting him out of
the side oh my gosh oh boy well he did
he did get that though he he made the
show 22 million listeners so we just
upped his ratings does he still do that
show
i think so is that show still on yeah i
see i don't have it i'm me my
television's never on except like
you know appointment something i don't
know football games football i do watch
football that's it yeah that's about it
but the occasional thing sharon makes me
watch and then football but
yeah i'm because i'm just firmly
convinced the news has completely lost
all their minds so yeah and so has
family feud who thought
a friendly game show i'll i bet is uh
what's the other one the uh wheel of
fortune is that's the one that's still
going big pat show john that's a jack
he's still alive he looks great you know
pat styx was a weather man here in
nashville i didn't know that before he
did that he was here back when i was a
kid there's your fun fact for the day
that's how old pat is
love you pat this is the ramsay show